hello I'm Ben Wattenberg on July 4th
1776 our founding fathers cut America's
ties with England by adopting the
Declaration of Independence the author
of their manifesto was only 33 years old
Thomas Jefferson philosopher diplomat
president slave holder and sometime
radical who was Thomas Jefferson and
what would he think of our nation today
joining us to sort through the conflict
and the consensus are judge Robert Bork
of the American Enterprise Institute and
author of the tempting of America
Professor Peter oneth the holder of the
Thomas Jefferson Memorial Foundation
chair at the University of Virginia and
editor of Jeffersonian legacies James
Oliver Horton a scholar of the
Jeffersonian era professor of history
and American Studies at George
Washington University and author of free
people of color inside the African
American community
and Jan Lewis of Rutgers University and
author of the pursuit of happiness
family and values in Jefferson's
Virginia the question before this house
what about Jefferson this week on
think-tank
[Music]
in 1962 at a dinner honoring Nobel Prize
winners President John F Kennedy said I
think this is the most extraordinary
collection of talent and of human
knowledge that has ever been gathered
together at the White House with the
possible exception of when Thomas
Jefferson dined alone some historians
say that Thomas Jefferson was the last
Renaissance man the author of the
Declaration of Independence and third
president of the United States spoke six
languages and was an accomplished
inventor naturalist mathematician and
architect Jefferson personally designed
his home Monticello as well as the
University of Virginia Jefferson's
greatest legacy of course is the
Declaration of Independence it is
probably the single most recognized and
copied political document in the world
it's powerful words still resonate
everywhere we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
now how could the man who wrote those
stirring words owned a hundred and fifty
slaves and unlike George Washington who
freed all of his slaves upon his death
Jefferson freed only five what he
thought slavery would not last declaring
nothing is more certainly written in the
book of faith than that these people are
to be free political life was not easy
for Jefferson his hatred of aristocracy
made him a strong supporter of the
French Revolution his enemies charged
that he was too fond of popular
uprisings calling him mad Tom and the
robes Pierre of the American mob but
supporters supporters hailed him as the
mammoth of democracy and as the man of
the people
he died on July 4th 1826 on his tomb he
asked to be remembered as the author of
the Declaration of Independence the
founder of the University of Virginia
and off
of the Virginia statute of religious
freedom professor ooph
Peter oneth let's start out what kind of
a man was he
Jefferson was an extraordinary man as
your list of his achievements indicates
we still don't know what to make of him
though I think the notion of Renaissance
man is a kind of fudge he's everything
which means that we don't really know
what he is what's most remarkable about
Jefferson the Democrat is that if
anybody represents the aristocratic
impulses in America before the
Revolution its Jefferson and his class
in Virginia in fact he's the cream of
the Virginia aristocracy and it's
remarkable that he could embrace these
ideas that we now it take to be the
defining ideas of democracy Jim Hardin
Jefferson is an extraordinary man was an
extraordinary man he was also a very
complicated man and in that regard I
think he becomes the personification
really of American society he is a
person of great principle but a person
who cannot always achieve that which his
principles would dictate I think the
same can be said of our society great
principles we don't always live up to
them Jen Jen Lois I'd like to go back to
a point that Peter made talk about this
conundrum a paradox that Jefferson is
the exponent of democracy yet in many
ways he comes from an aristocratic
background historians I don't think I've
ever been able to explain fully that
paradox how a man with such privilege
and in many ways maintains privilege in
that beautiful setting at Monticello how
he's able to go beyond his background
and come up with ideas that are supposed
to apply to all people and that all
people have chosen as their banner
Oh Bob Bob Bork judge Judge Bork lawyer
Bork and you are surrounded by
historians here
what do you make him Jefferson as a law
giver law writer I mean he that's what
he is is principally known as I guess
well if you mean the Declaration of
Independence of course that is really in
part of propaganda document it's a
rhetorical document it's not really part
of our law I suppose the Virginia
statute and religious freedom was a
great achievement but I don't think of
Jefferson primarily as a law giver why
why not I mean he well for one thing you
know if Jefferson's principles had
prevailed they would have destroyed the
United States the Union would have been
gone he thought for example that the the
states could nullify acts of Congress if
they thought they were each state
thought it was unconstitutional he
didn't believe in judicial review he
thought each branch of government could
decide constitutionality for itself
the what that was the great fight was
Chief Justice Marshall yes that was a
part of his fight with Marshall he
wanted a new constitutional convention
every 20 years
James Madison talked him out of that one
but obviously if these principles had
prevailed we would have had at the
states would have fragmented and the
Union would have been destroyed I think
it's only fair to say Bob that if
Hamilton's principles have prevailed the
same thing what had happened well the
good work was Jefferson a radical is
that is that fair to say I mean all this
stuff about watering the tree of liberty
with human blood every 20 years that
sort of rhetoric was radical and just to
get back to the point you were making
here his notions about being able to
review each state being able to review
and to decide congressional rulings for
themselves I mean that comes in the
context of the fear that he had that the
Federalists at a time the only Sedition
Acts were really concentrating power in
the hands of the federal government to a
dangerous extent so in some ways that
was a reaction I'm not sure that if the
context had been different he would have
held to that belief well certainly what
he interpreted the Constitution he
interpreted federal power very narrowly
and this would have been a very
different nation if he'd prevailed
let me ask you a question if if Thomas
Jefferson were alive today would he be a
Democrat or a Republican
my son doesn't introduce us by saying my
son who was 16 and his attendant many of
the festivities around Jefferson's 10
50th birthday last year got so
frustrated with this question that he
insisted if Thomas Jefferson were alive
today he'd be 250 years old
historians resist that sort of question
because the times were so
extraordinarily different that much said
I will say that we can follow different
parts of the Jeffersonian legacy and
they go in very different directions as
Bob is suggested there's a states rights
Jefferson that leads to nullification
and to the southern side of the Civil
War and you can see those ideas
developing at the same time there's
Jefferson the rights giver and who leads
to the sort of rights consciousness that
we associate with Liberal Democrats so
there's their different parts of his
legacy that lead in very different
directions
how could a man who I mean at times when
you read about it he sounds like sort of
an agrarian nut I mean he hates cities
he hates mobs he hates people in cities
how could a man like that see a member
of the Democratic Party today I mean he
distrust cities I think that's
misleading in any case that notion of
his hating cities is a very urbane man
he loves her vanity and civility that is
the good things that cities bring his
political project is an opposition to
the metropolis the concentration of
power that he resisted in the patriotic
resistance movement before the
Revolution and the danger that such
concentrations would be the emerge in
America under the aegis of the
Hamiltonian and to show you how complex
and how contradictory he was you're
absolutely right that he feared the
concentration of federal power but he
used federal power when he was in the
federal office when he was president of
the United States for example the
Louisiana Purchase which
expanded the sizing united's a several
times I which was unconstitutional which
was at least he was not sure that it was
constitutional and said that that he was
not sure it was well though
unconstitutionally the premise was
probably it was but there was a great
disconnect between Jefferson's words and
his actions as president in fact when he
was president he had to evade all of the
principles that had laid down before he
became president not only the Louisiana
Purchase but he sent off the Navy and
the Marine Corps to Tripoli to attack
the Barbary pirates without getting
congressional press right it's one of
the earliest presidents were president
initiating hostilities without a
declaration of war what about his visit
his attitude toward race and slavery how
do we how do we deal with that now
Jefferson what he was obviously a
slaveholder obviously a man who was
uncomfortable with the institution of
slavery who thought the institution of
slavery was wrong and even so could not
bring himself to free his own slaves he
only freed eight slaves his entire well
three during his lifetime five in his
will a man with some 200 slaves who
never moved to the position of
liberalism on the question of slavery
that many in his in his own time in his
own region did so although he was in
some ways a leader in terms of
democratic thinking he was he lagged
behind more progressive thinking on the
question of slavery even for his time
period
well did I think early on he proposed a
measure that no slavery would be allowed
in new states and he lost that by one
vote in the Congress sure but when the
new states were actually opening up 1820
he went exactly in the opposite
direction he denounced all that said
that slavery ought be allowed wherever
it would expand I think we have to
understand the limits of the notion of
equality and to some extent we have to
accept that when Jefferson articulates
universal principles he comes up against
difference which he can't accommodate in
this scheme
that is it's one of the aspects of
liberalism to generalize and
universalize rights that we define ever
more clearly the boundary between those
who are capable of burying rights and
those who are not this is where
Jefferson's racism comes to the fore
what we would call his racism he
naturalized difference he couldn't
accept artificial difference that is
aristocracy we're privileged families
would rule over others but there were
differences for instance in the family
between men men and women parents and
children between races he believed that
african-americans were naturally
inferior statements in the notes in the
state of Virginia about blacks they make
us extremely uncomfortable today and
that this is the paradox with the
Jeffers I mean he knows he absolutely
knows that slavery is wrong everyone at
the time know Jefferson is opposed to
slavery particularly at the time of the
Revolution there's no question where the
Declaration of Independence leads that
will lead to the elimination of slavery
at the same time
Jefferson plays around with and creates
a racism today that makes I think very
uncomfortable did Thomas Jefferson have
an affair with Sally Hemings a slave on
his plantation obviously we don't know
the answer to that question there are
lots of circumstantial evidence that he
did but there is no smoking gun I don't
know of anybody who could testify yes I
know for sure that he did but this
argument I would make against the
relationship and I don't like to put
myself in a position of defending
Jefferson on this as I think the main
reason why it's not likely to have
happened is that he was such a racist
and for him miscegenation mixing the
races blurring the line between black
and white created this unbearable
dissonance and tension many of us have
people in the Hemings connection were
light-skinned they were could have
passed for white and to perpetuate that
confusion of the races while you're
claiming that the races are so distinct
in their capabilities is to is to make
an unbearable situation yes but
would have been very much in keeping
with the kind of ethical dilemmas and
inconsistency that we know Jefferson had
routinely in his life Jan you you have
written about family life in of
Jefferson and his time where do you come
out on the great Sally Hemings mystery
oh I blame the nephews the family that
one child that was born exactly nine
months after he returns as ambassador
friends well the timing is that the
people have done this be true the timing
is such that Jefferson might have been
the father that he was in the vicinity
nine months before the birth of each of
Sally Hemings children so were the
nephews you're saying no one no one's
done the research on the nephews the
family thought that it was the nephews
and in fact many years afterwards when
they would say well we know it was it
was uncle it was Uncle Peter was a Uncle
Sam and what I find significant about
that is that even if Thomas Jefferson
himself were not the father of Sally
Hemings children which I think I would
agree with Peter not that's not likely
could be but not likely even if he
weren't by the family's own admission
these children where would have been
Jefferson's great nephews and nieces
they were family and I think that this
is a metaphor for race relations in this
country in that we're all in some way
family and we should all acknowledge
that we are all related that all of us
are the descendants of Thomas Jefferson
if not literally metaphorically let me
let me ask question here here you have
as we're talking here you have a man
who's certainly on the race issue does
not seem like the great exemplar and
trumpeter of human liberty and yet
around the world
forget about America for me Jefferson
not Washington not Hamilton is every
revolutionary in the world the good guys
as well as the totalitarians wave the
Declaration of Independence all men are
created equal self-determination
wait where is that hypocrisy
I mean well Forrest McDonald was
Nestorian said that Jefferson combined
deviousness slipperiness hypocrisy with
charm and grace and a sure sense of his
own purposes which are priceless assets
in a politician so that he did say a lot
does it remind you of anybody well you
know here you have the difference
between his actions and his words there
is great reverence with in 19th century
black society for his words the
conventions of blacks that were held
throughout the 1830s in the 1840s
started off every meeting with the
reading of the Declaration of
Independence so that in terms of his
words they were revered within the black
community because after all those black
people did believe all men were created
equal and so on actions he was a great
rhetoric aside and he cut off a lot of
phrases today we would identify with a
new left and which is why I think a lot
of his rhetoric is so popular in the
Galit Aryan age but he was not in the
gala tarry and he referred to the people
when he opposed the idea of direct
election of senators he referred to the
people as the swine each multitude the
swine a small dude that's a pretty good
bumper sticker very good for a
politician I think the I think the
problem is not formulated properly when
we talk about the disjunction between
words and actions I think we're looking
at the outside in we're saying what are
the boundaries how far do you go
Jefferson aha we found you we've caught
you out these are the limits you can't
be serious
this is just nonsense but if we start
with Jefferson's own experience of his
world and talk about what his
aspirations were then it looks
differently take the whole idea of
equality equality is the buzzword of the
Revolutionary period now we have
appropriated for our own multifarious
purposes now but for Jefferson and his
fellow Patriot leaders equality refers
specifically to their status in the
status of their colonies in the British
Empire it was grounded in a notion of
English rights it was very specific and
what Jefferson did was try to reach
beyond that not as far as we would like
him to perhaps but the idea that you
could form even a you
of liberty-loving free Americans was
itself a an act of faith an intellectual
leap so if we look at it from
Jefferson's perspective inside out
then I think we have rather a different
view than if we take this perspective of
why doesn't he why isn't he good enough
for us today why doesn't it do what we
do we politically correct moderns but
let's not judge him by the standards of
our time let's judge him by the
standards of his own time there are
people in in his own time who risks
their careers who risk their fortunes in
ways that are far more egalitarian than
Jefferson than Jefferson was willing to
do let's move on for a moment to the to
the legacy of Jefferson Magog yym n't
between Jefferson and Hamilton about
what kind of America are we going to
have Jefferson so they're taking this
rural agrarian view and Hamilton writing
the what does it call about manufactures
a report on manufactures looking toward
a booming muscular sort of industrial
society is it fair then to say given
what America is today that the true
father of this America is Hamilton not
Jefferson it seems to me that really
that they both are mean what we get out
of the Hamiltonian legacy is a strong
active huge federal government as a
centralized government but we still have
also the Jefferson suspicion of a strong
government and it's in space between
those two the actuality of a centralized
state and an American suspicion of a
centralized state that's where American
history is made I think it's wrong to
think of either of them as the father of
the country this country would have
developed as it did if Jefferson and
Hamilton had never existed
Jefferson's idea of an agrarian society
was doomed from the beginning
he couldn't couldn't succeed look live
in this world as an agrarian society we
would be run up overrun by their powers
and the growth of the central government
was a natural development people wanted
it George Washington immediately began
proposing projects that were well
outside the federal power in the
Constitution
your current argument that you make
these days you would have been making
that in 1790 that these guys are using
too much too much federal power more
than the Constitution gave them well the
Constitution certainly doesn't give the
federal government the power it now has
but the Constitution could not stop the
federal power from growing there's no
way it can stop it
I think the strong central government
was in the cards whatever the
Constitution said I think we
misunderstand
Jefferson's legacy if we think of him
simply as an agrarian this quaint figure
who's attached to a romanticized past
who resists modernity and all the ills
associated with it I think Jefferson
instead his impact on American history
has been to authorize in the licensed
private initiative a release of energy
his preference for agriculture is a
preference for commercial agriculture
and the initiatives of individual
farmers and then traders as well he
believed that the force developed
manufacturers as Hamilton was going to
do would in fact be retrograde would not
compare contribute to the wealth of the
nation or its future prosperity and you
could argue that through much of the
19th century until the great
concentrations of capital that emerge in
the Civil War and afterwards that this
was the prescription this was the
formula that was going to make America
the way it was so I think there was a
choice early on and it is significant
that the the Jeffersonian the
Jeffersonian emerged in power with the
so-called revolution of 1800 about
Jefferson in the world I mean what what
what would this what did that piece of
paper mean that Declaration of
Independence forget America from it's
complicated and we've explored it forget
America that's a easy one right Bob is
is that the Revolutionary document of
the world well I think as the world
becomes increasingly a gala terraeum the
Declaration becomes an inspiration to
people and that's true I think
throughout Western civilization and it's
been used by good guys and bad guys well
sure but I think that probably the most
important thing here is it it provides
stone for those people who are oppressed
it is a document to which they can turn
to which they can appeal it becomes a
way of appealing to the conscious of the
of the nation and without that document
without us saying to the world this is
what we believe it becomes very
difficult for oppressed people within
the country to appeal to a conscience to
say if you say you believe that you must
act in that way and it seems to me
that's the importance of the Declaration
Jefferson didn't always do it but the
fact that he put this decoration there
makes it possible for us to have a
touchstone I think there's another
dimension of Jeffersonian thought having
to do with equality that relates to this
and that is the Equality that Jefferson
hoped to achieve as I mentioned before
was the Equality of the American
colonies and that notion of equality
applied to States and to Nations as I
think the probably the most significant
Jeffersonian legacy on the level of
rhetoric it's human equality that we
refer to but it's really national
self-determination nation making the
independence of states that's been I
think the great legacy of the American
Revolution and of Jefferson's
Declaration okay thank you professor
peter oneth professor James Horton
professor Jan Ellen Lewis judge Robert
Bork and thank you we have appreciated
hearing from you very much please send
any comments or questions to the address
on the screen
[Music]
for think-tank I'm been wattenberg
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content